-As COVID cases are,
once again, surging
and a new variant is spreading,
Republicans are claiming,
falsely,
that Democrats want
to return to lockdowns
and suggesting that you can use
mouthwash to treat COVID.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
With holiday travel, COVID cases
are, once again, on the rise
and, now, there's a new variant
that, early indications suggest,
is even more transmissible
than Delta,
called the Omicron variant.
We got one of our
earliest introductions
to how the virus spreads
from a large gathering
in New York City recently.
-The CDC has now contacted
more than 35,000 people
who attended a recent animé
convention in New York City
to alert them
of a COVID case there.
Scientists believe
the convention could give them
the earliest looks at the spread
of Omicron in the U.S.
-Hey, COVID, you leave
our animé conventions alone!
[ Laughter ]
If animé fans
can't talk to each other
in a convention setting,
they're going to bring it
to the office,
and nobody wants that!
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, just FYI,
there was a new 'Sailor Moon'
last night,
so, maybe steer clear of Dave."
[ Laughter ]
And it's an extra bummer,
since Omicron
sounds exactly like a character
name from animé.
[ Laughter ]
That must've been weird
for the contact tracers.
I'm calling to let you know
you may have come in contact
with Omicron
at the animé convention.
"Aw, no way!
I should've got an autograph!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, by the way,
I'm saying all of this
as a self-identified
comic book fan.
I am not judging.
It is hard to find people
with the same interests.
I mean, when I worked at "SNL,"
I used to go to Lorne's office
and ask him who his favorite
"Spider-Man" character was
and he'd say Norman Osborn.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Michaels ]
You know, everyone focuses
on the Green Goblin,
but they forgot
Oscorp did some
really good things.
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way, if COVID can
spread at an animé convention,
can you imagine how bad it'll be
at other mass gatherings?
Have you ever been to SantaCon?
That thing was
a superspreader event
[ Laughter ]
before COVID even existed.
If you have children,
I beg of you,
keep them away from midtown
during SantaCon.
It will scar them
for the rest of their lives.
[ Laughter ]
And I know from experience.
I'll never forget
my kids saying,
"Daddy, why is Santa peeing
on a police car?"
[ Laughter ]
Uh, well, uh...
that cop was very bad this year
and Santa's out of coal.
[ Laughter ]
So they detected Omicron
at an animé convention,
which then allowed it
to spread to other states.
Yesterday,
CNN interviewed someone
with one of the earliest cases,
who, thankfully,
had only very mild symptoms
and quickly recovered,
which he credited to the fact
that he was vaccinated,
although the anchors
still seemed a little suspicious
when he started sniffling.
-So tell us
about your experience
of getting sick with Omicron.
What were your symptoms?
What was it like?
-Yeah, I had a very light
what I thought was a cold --
fatigue, cough, runny nose --
which only lasted
about 24 hours.
I'm very pro-vaccine
and I think,
because of me getting
the booster and my vaccine,
that I was able to recover
so fast
and my symptoms were so mild.
[ Sniffle ]
-Peter, are you okay now?
It sounds like you got
the sniffles, a little nasally.
What's going on?
How you feeling?
-No. Unfortunately,
living in Minnesota,
it's freezing cold
all the time, so,
just the air gets to me
and I also have asthma,
so it's just like it's
an ongoing thing my entire life.
[ Laughter ]
But I feel 100%.
-Alright.
I was just checking.
[ Laughter ]
I heard a little sniffle
and a little nasally.
Just making sure you're alright.
-Unfortunately, this is just
how I sound all the time.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, now I feel bad.
-Yeah.
-Hey, man, I know what you're
going through.
I have asthma and I carry
an inhaler with me all the time.
I keep it at the desk in case
Sal writes some long, wordy run
where there's no time
for me to take a breath.
Plus, I need it after I do
my Mike Lindell impression
because I don't know how
that guy does it, but I've --
[ As Lindell ]
Never seen him take a breath!
[ Laughter ]
So I stand in solidarity
with you, Peter.
But it's a sign of just
how paranoid we've all gotten,
that we hear a few sniffles
and we all turn
into virologists.
I mean, hearing a cough
on the subway now
is like hearing a twig snap
in a horror movie.
[ Laughter ]
And, if I show any symptoms
of a cold at home,
I have to make up a story,
so my wife doesn't make me stay
at a hotel.
"Um, why are you sniffling?"
Um, I was, uh,
doing some cocaine
with NYU students?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You better be telling
the truth."
[ Laughter ]
The point is, pandemic life
sucks, we all hate it,
but as much as we may be done
with COVID,
COVID is not done with us.
That's just the reality.
Thankfully,
we have so many more tools
at our disposal now
to deal with it,
like vaccines, boosters,
high-quality masks,
ventilation, and rapid tests,
which everyone
should have access to.
Trying to get your hands
on a rapid test right now
is like trying to buy
a Tamagotchi in the '90s.
[ Laughter ]
And if you don't get
that reference,
the '90s were a decade
that happened
10 years before you were born.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Before Tom Holland,
there was Tam Agotchi.
[ Boisterous laughter
and applause ]
That's my Tom Holland!
[ Laughter ]
The new one
won't let me feed 'im!
[ Laughter ]
In other developed nations,
rapid tests are all either
super cheap and widely available
or provided for free
by the government,
which is how it should be here.
Instead, the Biden
administration has, somehow,
come up with the worst
of all possible options --
by the test yourself,
then get reimbursed
by your insurance provider.
-Now, two years
into this pandemic
and the thing we needed
in month one
is still the thing
that we need today --
widespread, easy, rapid testing.
Last week, President Joe Biden
announced his plan
to have private insurers
cover the cost of at-home tests,
meaning you can buy a test,
submit the cost,
and your insurance
will reimburse you for it.
-Have you ever tried
to get reimbursed
by an insurance provider?
There are like
80 pages of forms to fill out
and, inevitably,
you get a letter
six months later that says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
A situation like this is when
it really becomes clear
just how screwed up our
for-profit medical system is.
This week, a reporter suggested
the insurance
reimbursement system
might be too complicated,
and asked why we can't
just provide free tests,
like other countries, and then,
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki
mocked the question
by jokingly asking
if the White House should just
send free tests out in the mail.
-There are still
a lot of countries,
like Germany
and the UK and South Korea,
that basically have
massive testing,
free of charge
or for a nominal fee.
Why can't that be done
in the United States?
-Well, I would say, first,
you know,
we have eight tests that have
been approved by the FDA here
and this effort to push
to ensure insurers --
you're are able to get your --
your tests refunded means
150 million Americans
will be able to get free tests.
Why not just make them free
and give them out
and have them
available everywhere?
-Should we just send one
to every American?
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
You should send a test
to every Amer--
I mean, if Pottery Barn
can send every American
[ Laughter ]
eight catalogs a year,
you should be able
to pull off one.
You know what? Maybe we should
just outsource this
to Pottery Barn and let them
put ads on the swabs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Seriously,
why is that ridiculous?
Other countries
with public health systems
are already doing it...
Of course, over there,
they're not called rapid tests.
They're called...
[ Laughter ]
I know!
I also think that's dumb!
We desperately need easy access
to free, rapid testing
for anyone who wants it,
on top of our vaccines,
boosters, and masks.
We have so many more tools now
than we did back in March 2020,
which is why
we don't need lockdowns.
Biden has already
ruled out lockdowns, for now,
and I think it's safe to say
no one wants to go back to that,
Democrat or Republican.
I don't want to go back
to my attic
[ Laughter ]
and I certainly don't want to go
back to my in-laws' house.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, now, real quick,
I need to film an alternate
version of that for my in-laws,
and then we'll edit it in
and then, this will be
the "Closer Look" we show them.
Alright, ready?
I don't want to go back
to my attic,
but I wouldn't mind going back
to my in-laws' house,
because I love it there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone's super chill
and they always sing karaoke
with perfect pitch.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, back to the real
"Closer Look."
I don't want to go back
to my [bleep] in-laws' house!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thankfully, Biden has
ruled that out, for now,
although, you wouldn't know it
from Fox News,
which has been lying for days
about Democrats threatening
to shut everything down again
over Omicron.
-Democrats are already
using this to jam through
their pro-lockdown,
anti-freedom agenda.
-They want us to go
on shutdown, lockdown, again.
-Then they want
to implement
more ridiculous lockdowns.
-They want us
to lock down our lives,
with no information,
lock down our kids' lives,
with no information.
-The Biden administration is,
once again,
locking down the country
and persecuting its perceived
political opponents,
otherwise known
as the unvaccinated.
So you have to ask yourself,
"When will this end?"
Viruses mutate constantly.
That's their nature.
Will every new "Omeecron"
variant mean massive new
[ Laughter ]
and unconstitutional powers
for our political class?
-[ As Carlson ]
When will it end?
[ Laughter ]
Will every new variant mean
new powers
for our political class?
Will they be able to test you,
trace you,
come to your house
and inject you with a microchip,
hidden in a vaccine,
that tracks your movements?
And what that tracking microchip
allow them to see
that you went to the animé
convention in secret, of course,
[ Laughter ]
because you didn't want
your friends at Fox News
to know that you're
into that kind of thing.
And will they find out about the
time you asked Sean Hannity
what he thought
of "Dragon Ball Z"
[ Laughter ]
and he looked at you
like you were crazy
and that hurt
your feelings so much
that you ran
into the bathroom to cry,
only to realize that you had run
into the women's bathroom
[ Laughter ]
and were so worried
that someone would see you
run out,
that you, instead,
removed a ceiling panel
[ Laughter ]
and climbed into a heating duct
for the purposes of shimmying
back to your office,
not knowing that the duct
wouldn't be strong enough
to support your weight,
[ Laughter ]
causing you to, mid-shimmy,
collapse through the ceiling,
where you landed on top
of Rupert Murdoch's desk
while he was sitting at it,
causing him to look up from his
soup and yell, "Crikey!"?
[ Laughter ]
Will that happen to you?
Well, I can tell you it will.
Because it happened to me.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I want to revisit that
Don Jr. clip from the montage
because he had more to say,
specifically,
about Dr. Anthony Fauci.
-If you look at, you know,
let's call it an elf
with a Napoleonic complex,
bureaucrat Fauci,
he doesn't know
what he's talking about.
He's a bureaucrat.
He's not a good doctor.
He's better
at being a bureaucrat.
And, as long
as we keep giving that clown
his 15 minutes of fame,
the TV that he
so desperately craves,
we're going to be in these
lockdown situations forever.
-I'm sorry, he's an elf
[ Laughter ]
with a Napoleonic complex?
You're so desperate
to look taller,
you stand with your nipples
pointed out,
like you're using them
as weapons.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Don Jr. ]
Stay away from me, antifa!
These bad boys will hurt you!
[ Laughter ]
Also, I wouldn't call anyone
an elf,
when you literally posed
for a photo
on a stump in the woods,
like a troll who got kicked out
of the Fellowship of the Rings.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, yes,
I'm aware there were no trolls
in that fellowship.
That's why they go sit
on stumps.
So, Republicans are, as usual,
lying about lockdowns
and vaccines.
Instead, they'd rather focus
on absurd,
unproven remedies,
like hydroxychloroquine
or ingesting bleach,
or this new one,
from Wisconsin Senator
Ron Johnson -- mouthwash.
-I want you to listen
to Republican
Senator Ron Johnson
at a town hall
just this week.
-Or, even better,
don't use mouthwash,
and your bad breath
will keep people
six feet away from you
at all times.
[ Laughter ]
Listerine
explicitly states on its website
that its product...
I don't even want
to imagine what's next.
Is Titleist going to have
to issue a statement
that says...
[ Laughter ]
We have proven tools
at our disposal
to protect people
from this virus,
but right-wing politicians
and media figures
are intent on fearmongering
and lying about it.
Santa himself
could get vaccinated
and they'd tell you he was
forced by a...
-Elf with a Napoleonic complex.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.